hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we're gonna be talking about the
new heroes coming in year four but not
exactly the way that you might expect so
obviously at this current moment that
I'm making the video we don't know
anything about the heroes just yet so I
thought as a little bit of an idea to
maybe fluctuate some ideas from the
community and maybe even giving you guys
some ideas of the new character I'm
going to be showing some actual
community related ideas and see what we
can come up with now some of these may
include actual drawings some of these
may not I'm trying to pick a wide
variety of the bunch here and you guys
know how I am about art so whenever I
find something that has to do with art I
will credit the person accordingly with
the reddit post that is linked in any
other art station deviantART Twitter's
that I can find related to the same
person but yes it is gonna be a nice
sweet and relaxing video so sit back and
let's enjoy some of these hero concepts
together so as always like the V if you
enjoy subscribe if you're new let's get
started with today's video so first up
is Mick rough on Reddit and it's not an
image of a character but more of a
moveset of the weapon the hero would be
holding the weapon off the bat looks
like Wolverine claws but I believe the
actual name of the weapon from some
helpful people in the comments is called
a tech oekaki or hand claws this is
mostly used by ninjas back in the old
days I believe the original origin and
reasoning for the tech oekaki was a farm
tool it was a kind of sickle used for
reaping the weeds during planting and
the specialty of ninjas of course was
that they would use anything for a
weapon and this was no exception the
shape of the tech Okabe was for iron
nails with bear claw like attached to a
metal ring when used the ninja wood
grest the oval ring and scratch his
enemy with the edges of the claws a rope
was tied around the ninjas very tightly
as so it didn't lose grip and usually
they would wear one on each hint these
are mostly used by ninjas when in a
weapon to weapon combat situation having
two one-handed weapons allows for
swifter moving so it obviously be super
helpful for fighting which is why it was
used now obviously this weapon has been
modernized by other people with other
designs which of course could translate
to the legendary and epic variants of
the weapon but for the default base its
just iron as for the actual move list I
want to say right off the bat as well
that don't judge these from a balanced
standpoint of course this is more just
of a creative idea since these are
probably not coming to the game
time soon and even if they did Ubisoft
would balance these accordingly if these
are too overpowered so don't worry about
balance just think of more from the
creativity of the idea for the moves
though off the riff we have the infinite
chain of lights or heavies it seems like
it's a combination of both of some of
the characters so some characters need
to do heavy light heavy light
back-to-back and then some just need to
do topside topside doesn't matter the
attack at all as long as it's from the
top to the side of the sides at the top
you have to alternate it seems like this
is a combination of both and you could
do any side you want in any kind of
combo you want it's just unending it
seems to me that the only way to
actually stop this combo is by either
them running out of stamina or to parry
or do something like our mushas full
block for example we also have three
dash attacks with the move set the
forward and side dash lights are just
normal dash attacks the forward inside -
heavies have a bleed property and the
forward inside - with the GP input
afterwards is more of a kick attack
which pushes the enemy backwards now one
thing new to this hero and new to any
hero pretty much is that it has three
different GB variations and three
deflect variations four deflects a
simple unblockable which is pretty
standard for some D flex we don't want
another Ducie deflect heavy is also
unblockable but has a bleed attack and
deflects evm to be a kick or a sweep
that knocks the opponent on the floor
for the jeebies it's as you'd expect
guard break light is pretty normal
guard break heavy is a bleed and guard
break followed by another guard break or
a throw in this case is also unblockable
but we'll get into the reason for that
in just one second because now we have
the hero specific tab which says
all-white openers and chain heavies have
superior block this hero also has chain
dodges during a chain you can dodge
dodge attack or deflect without stopping
the chain and cat pounce
tiger pounce rip breaker rip the guts
will deal extra damage when used in
chain and spinning kick and stay down
will drain more stamina and when used in
a chain as well to break this down cap
pounce
as said before is the light dodge
attacks tiger pounds is the heavy dodge
attacks rip breaker is the deflect light
and rip the guts is deflect heavy all
dealing more damage in chains I can see
this D flag part being very nice for
characters with hyper armor individuals
it seems like this character is really
meant to stop attacking
either when the opponent is dead or when
they're out of stamina and speaking of
stamina we have the spinning kick which
is the - jeebies and stay down which is
the D flight be doing increased stamina
when use thin chains it seems like
they're going to be doing stamina damage
anyway but of course when used in a
chain attack they'll be doing even more
I don't think I need to explain what
this means so I think you at the point
we'll be talking about the GB variant in
one second because the second last part
is the chain finishers you can end any
chain of a combo after or at the third
strike of the chain of course utilizing
the entire kit at your disposal by
either holding heavy attack for an
unblockable heavy or a holding guard
break for a GB and that's how that you
can end combos lastly we get to the
guard break throws kick and throw which
is G B and then G B again drains stamina
before throwing the enemy but we'll
drain more if it's the chain to finish
your guard break stab and throw which is
the G B light and scratch and throw
which is the G B heavy will deal more
damage if it's the chain to finisher
guard break as opposed to the normal G B
from neutral now my only question though
with this is that what's really the
point of the guard break light compared
to the guard break heavy of course from
neutral the heavies going to do more
damage and it has the bleed property and
even if it's from the chain finisher
it's still going to do more bleed and
also just more damage in general so it
feels like the guard break into light is
useless in some ways overall this sounds
cool it's definitely giving me some
vibes from Zeng he from dynasty Warriors
also the game Ninja Gaiden as they wield
similar weapons now that was a
definitely a longer one in terms of
character development so we're gonna try
to ease into this one a little bit
smaller this time like I said this isn't
going to be as deep with character
development but we do have an image for
it by the wolfdog art corner on reddit's
and at wolfdog also has a twitter
account which is wolfdog art and a
deviant art which is wolfdog art corner
so definitely go check his stuff I has
some fantastic pieces of other foreigner
heroes he's made as well some original
drawings and even some apex hero designs
like this Gibraltar skin so please
support his work and everything he does
but today's piece we're gonna be talking
about his take on the Secutor and that's
not just a fancy name that's an actual
gladiatorial name Secutor is a class of
gladiators in ancient Rome at this is
translated to follower or chaser they
usually will beggar short swords or
Gladius ha's and were
exceptionally terrifying against the
light armored opponents like the right
arias which is a gladiator with a net
and I tried wolfdog also left some nice
porn errs on the picture as well going
from top to bottom we have the guard
stances he or she will be using when
wielding the weapons the helmet is
definitely heavily detailed with some
bigger areas for paint to shine on the
helmets as well as these shoulder wings
on the shoulder which can change
depending on cosmetics but the way that
I see it with these year three
characters this is probably going to be
passing as an ornament not just a
default look that will be changed on the
character depending on the armor they
wear I think this is just going to be
its own separate thing as an ornament
the hero will always have the suktam
shield which will change design and trim
for customization purposes and the
weapon will be used to of course stab
and slash opponents now like we stated
before with the weapon that could be
either be daggers short swords or
Gladius
now with the thing with the Gladius is
that that is Centurions weapon and I'm
assuming they don't want to copy the
same weapon so they'll probably have a
dagger or most likely have a short sword
if this hero comes to the live game and
then lastly we come to the legs and both
legs are armored but the right leg is
more metal and the left leg is more
padded as opposed to actual metal since
the right foot will usually be in the
front when guarding and since obviously
that one's going to be in the back the
less armor these people wear the faster
they move but they also need armor to
protect themselves so it's kind of a
give-and-take with some of this armor as
a guy who plays gladiator way more than
he wants to admit I'm literally in love
with this character this is an excuse
for a new Roman faction to come to the
game and I'm here for it absolutely
fantastic drawing and character idea and
while some might say this is another BP
I would highly disagree with you so let
me know what you think about that
comment and also for some comment
interaction since wolfdog didn't come up
with any moves that the character would
have let me know what you would add to
this character I think a full block of
move is very necessary judging by how
big this shield is and could work like
warlord wear with a block they can add a
quick jab if the opponent hits when in
that defensive mode and I think a bash
could work as well but because it's such
a huge shield and they have to be a lot
more longer of an attack but more
devastating hit instead of the usual
like whaa conquer and black prior have
where it's faster but you know just kind
of knocks them back a little bit maybe
even add a feat like shoo go key cuz she
go key has a fever his heavies when they
hit they knocked the opponent down
there could be a feat we're hit if his
bashes hit that can knock down people
using that feat as well but once again
I'm not taking balance into account I'm
just doing a lot of creative ideas for
the character cuz these might be fun to
play around with and yeah that's gonna
be today's video guys they guys for
coming along if you guys do enjoy this
I'll gladly make a part 2 part 3
whatever it comes to I didn't want to
make this video super long and I had no
idea that the very beginning character
was gonna take up a lot of this video so
that's why there's only two characters
I'll try to get to a couple more new
ones in the future video if you guys do
want that definitely let me know in the
comments below and by leaving a like if
you want me to do more of these videos
cuz this stuff is fantastic and I like
kind of exploring new ideas for
characters even if it's maybe not the
best from a balance standpoint yeah what
that don't like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new guys I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the patch notes and leaks as
well as doing some one-off videos on the
site like this if you wanted to catch
the date with everything happening
within the world of foreigner and never
miss out when enough the deficit a
subscribe the channel
take care guys hope yours today peace
out
[Music]
[Music]